bonjour à tous et ben voilà je suis
aujourd'hui avec mon vélo alors j'ai un
problème sur mon vélo parce que j'ai le
frein arrière qui est cassé et en fait
le problème c'est que j'en ai besoin
tous les jours pour aller travailler de
mon vélo pour aller à la rédaction alors
heureusement il existe les ateliers
bicyclette à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
l'objectif de l'association c'est de
vous former en fait à la réparation de
votre vélo vous êtes formé vous-même à
réparer votre vélo et on a rendez-vous
avec Benoît un bénévole de l'association
qui va nous expliquer comment réparer
tout ça et remettre le VTT sur pied
allez c'est parti
bonjour Benoît bonjour Julien merci de
merci beaucoup merci de nous recevoir
ici l'atelier bicyclette est-ce que du
coup vous pouvez peut-être m'expliquer
aussi quel est l'objectif de ces
ateliers l'objectif de l'atelier
vicyclette c'est de rendre les gens
autonomes effectivement sur leur vélo de
leur proposer un atelier de réparation
chose qu'ils ont pas forcément chez eux
et de les rendre autonome pour réparer
leur vélo dès qu'il y a une petite
réparation une maintenance à faire
dessus qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
réparer ici ce que tout est réparable
déjà et alors tout est réparable pas
forcément mais toutes les réparations
standard sur un vélo que soit frein ou
transmission on peut vraiment faire tout
ça sur le vélo effectivement si le cadre
va commencer à être cassé ça ça atteint
les limites de réparation qu'on peut
faire mais sinon pour la maintenance
globale du vélo on peut vraiment tout
faire ici alors justement aujourd'hui
Benoît j'ai un problème avec mon frein
du coup mon frein arrière et il est
sectionné effectivement je crois qu'il
est en fin de vie
je sais pas si possible de faire quelque
chose oui on va s'occuper de ça super et
bah c'est parti
tu ne fais que le dessert il y a pas
besoin de le dévisser complètement
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va sortir tout le câble ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu dois quand même le glisser ici de
toute façon donc là je l'ai passé là et
je le glisse à travers le
[Musique]
montant là franchement
normalement ce qu'on va vérifier donc
normalement ça passe du changer mais que
c'est pas ça soit bien parallèle
[Musique]
il faut d'abord desserrer ça
donc
tu peux y aller
juste au dessous ça doit pouvoir se
coincer
ah oui c'est juste ok oui d'accord ok et
bien merci beaucoup Benoît
et que non c'est super ça va me sauver
la vie franchement ça devrait beaucoup
mieux marché et ben voilà mon vélo
freine de nouveau parfaitement je suis
super content alors pour l'adhésion
sachez que c'est 10 euros par an et par
personne et c'est 18 euros si vous êtes
une famille vous allez pouvoir retrouver
tous les renseignements sur le site
internet de bicyclette quant à moi je
reprends la route donc bonne route à
tous à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines